J'aime bien l'expression de mon neveu,
quand il était tout petit,
quand on lui demandait
“Que fait ton oncle ?”,
il disait “C’est le chef du village”.
Jérôme Sourisseau,
je suis né à Cognac, en Charente.
De formation,
je suis agrégé de physique-chimie
et je suis devenu chef d'établissement scolaire,
puis engagé en politique.
D’abord comme militant
parce que j'ai commencé à adhérer au CDS
quand j'avais 18 - 19 ans.
Je suis toujours resté fidèle à cette famille
jusqu'au MoDem aujourd'hui.
Je suis maire de Bourg-Charente,
qui est une commune
d'un peu moins de 1000 habitants,
quasiment attouchée à la ville de Cognac
et président de l'agglomération
de Grand Cognac.
À l'époque,
je me suis engagé à l'UDF et plus particulièrement,
puisque c'était un rassemblement de familles,
au Centre des Démocrates Sociaux.
Je me suis rendu à ses universités d'été à Seignosse
et là, j'ai rencontré beaucoup de militants.
On a beaucoup échangé sur le fond
et ça correspondait
complètement à mes valeurs.
Et je me suis engagé à ce moment là
et je n'ai jamais quitté cette famille.
La France,
sa tradition, c'est de faire marier l'ensemble
et d'emporter tout le monde,
d'aller loin, d’être exigeant, de laisser des libertés,
mais aussi de tendre la main
à celui qui est le plus en difficulté,
qui est sur le bord de la route.
Je trouve que cette famille politique
incarne beaucoup de choses,
mais notamment ça,
c’était une des choses qui m'a vraiment attirée
quand j'avais 18 - 20 ans.
Il se trouve que pour les élections de 2008,
l'ancien maire, qui était assez âgé,
avait décidé de ne pas se représenter.
Donc très rapidement,
j'ai constitué une liste
et donc du coup, j'ai été élu en 2008.
J’aime bien l’expression de mon neveu,
quand il était tout petit,
quand on lui demandait
“Que fait ton oncle ?”,
il disait “C’est le chef du village”.
J'aime bien cette expression
parce que
ce n'est pas le chef au sens autoritaire.
Mais j'ai toujours
vécu dans cette commune,
donc je connais tout le monde,
je connais toutes les familles,
j'ai accompagné tout le monde
pour les bons moments de la vie,
les mauvais, on connaît chaque recoin,
on est une référence,
on est un repère et on accompagne tout le monde
dans la grande discrétion
ceux qui sont vraiment en difficulté,
comme ceux qui réussissent.
C’est extrêmement diversifié.
C'est un mandat passionnant, exigeant,
mais c'est un mandat passionnant.